it's time for drew's news your joy ride
down good news falls and with me at the
desk
is two besties i'd love to hop in a
barrel and float on down the river with
it's cameron auntie poopoo jazz
[Applause]
and together they make auntie rossi poo
all right um
i want to dedicate this uh segment to
you
when i was trying to basically let's
face it it was an audition
and um i really felt strongly about this
particular segment it was very personal
for me
to convince everybody of this idea i had
to put it in the sales tape and sell
this segment so
of course uh i'm gonna take you back to
that audition sales tape let's look back
at the very first drew's news in history
the one thing i don't like doing with
you is hiking because you have these
giant great like german shepherds and
you have these long legs you are a great
dane and i have these short dogs and the
legs of a corgi dog
and i literally can't keep up with you
no it's it's a kind of a comedy act i
look back she's like
she's like seething her face she's just
so angry at me i know i have to stop
every five seconds i'm like come on
let's go what's the matter
it's like a gazelle and an armadillo
that's what us hiking looks like
so um thank you for helping me convince
everyone of this segment my pleasure
it was a hard sell and you know i also
think when it came to that banter that
camaraderie that bouncing off each other
talking about the news stories and then
sharing feelings and opinions about it
when you're alone you don't have anyone
to do that with so rossi ross matthews
thank god showed up and saved a girl
[Applause]
[Music]